the curtain is finally up for To Kill a
Mockingbird at the Smith Center and
Jillian joins us with special guest
actor Richard Thomas
hi you guys Yes To Kill a Mockingbird
officially opened its curtains last
night here at the Smith Center and I am
joined by very special guest Richard
Thomas Richard thank you so much for
being here thanks for having me it's
wonderful to be in Las Vegas with this
play we're so happy to have you here you
kicked it off last night what was the
experience like how did it go well you
know when you're on tour the first thing
you you want to find out what is the
theater like and what is the audience
going to be like in this town and the
theater is so beautiful it's a and the
Acoustics are wonderful and the audience
was so warm and so appreciative and we
had a great Rapport last night it was a
really terrific experience I'm looking
forward to the rest of the week well we
really are happy to have you here and
you are no stranger to the stage to the
TV screen you do it all but what Drew
you into this role Atticus Finch I mean
one of the most iconic roles of all time
well I think you've answered the
question in the question I mean it's a
great it's a great character he's a it's
a terrific role and especially so in the
version that Aaron Sorkin has written
because he's he's made great changes to
the role of Atticus Finch and made him
very approachable and warm and funny and
and
not such an iconic person on the stage
just a person absolutely and to get to
jump into that character you started on
Broadway when you were just seven years
old right that's right how do you kind
of get your mindset to go from TV to the
stage to a live audience it's a little
bit different well we are used to it
that's what we do and so if you're
fortunate enough to work in all the
mediums you you're able to just
downshift and upshift and down your
regulate an up regulate according to
what the different venues you know
require
um yeah it's been a long road I mean my
my Actors Equity Union card will be 65
years old next year
congratulations quite the career and it
just continues to grow and grow this is
only the tip of the iceberg of
everything that you've done but what are
you hoping when people come see you in
the show what do you want them to take
away well what I want them to take away
is the full experience of this beautiful
play
um and the res it's very funny it's very
you know it's a it's tragic it's comic
it's a it's a real emotional roller
coaster ride it has so much in it and so
rich and primarily I want people to be
entertained I want them to be thinking
deeply and seriously about the issues in
the play but I also want them to have
had a wonderful emotional experience and
a wonderful time you know to laugh as
well and and uh that's the thing it's
not so much about seeing Atticus as it
is about having the whole experience of
the story well and Richard you are the
one to do that in that role and I know
everyone is going to be so excited to
see you so coming up next we're going to
dive a little bit deeper into your past
career and what led you to here but for
now be sure to check out tequila
Mockingbird